Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件目前正在进行的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, what is the difference between stress and burnout? How might we recognize
这些原则都同样适用。Lisa本人还会提供非常棒的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。今天我们要讨论的是：压力和倦怠之间有什么区别？我们该如何识别
that in ourselves and how might we help our clients to understand that too? That is the topic of today's episode. I hope you find this so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. This is part of a series of episodes called Burnout Bites, which is being hosted for me, for us, by Dr. Claire Plumley, who is incredible. burnout and you can learn more about that in the show notes. I really want to model to you guys, whoever you are, whether you are listening because you work in mental health and you're an aspiring psychologist or whether you're listening because you have an interest in your mental health or that of someone that you care about, I want you to know that it's always okay to ask for help. It never makes you look weak and it's always a great thing to do and that's what I am modeling with this special podcast series they are all standalone episodes but they are all grouped together under
我们自身的这些状态，又该如何帮助我们的客户理解这一点？这就是今天节目的主题。希望这对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。这是名为“倦怠小贴士”（Burnout Bites）系列节目的一部分，由非常出色的Claire Plumley博士为我们主持。关于倦怠，你可以在节目说明中了解更多。我真的想为你们所有人树立一个榜样，无论你是为了工作在心理健康领域而收听，还是因为对心理健康或关心之人的健康感兴趣，我想让你知道，寻求帮助永远是可以的。这绝不会让你显得软弱，这永远是一个很棒的选择，这也是我通过这个特别播客系列所展示的。这些都是独立的剧集，但它们都归类在
the term of burnout or should I say anti-burnout and it's a really really brilliant fit for this podcast because if you're a long-term listener you will know that I often ask people at the end of the podcast what their top tip for reducing burnout is. So I love that we've got Dr. Claire talking us through this in more detail. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Hello and welcome back to Burnout Bites. This is a short series of episodes where I'm talking all about burnout in the hope that you can learn a little bit more about this topic to keep yourself as safe as possible from it and of course the people you work with as well. I'm Dr Claire Plumley. I'm a clinical psychologist. I work with people who
“倦怠”或者我应该说是“反倦怠”的标题下。这与本播客非常契合，因为如果你是长期听众，你就会知道我经常在播客结束时问嘉宾减少倦怠的秘诀是什么。所以我很高兴Claire博士能为我们详细讲解。期待在节目之后与大家交流。你好，欢迎回到“倦怠小贴士”。这是一个简短的系列节目，我将讨论关于倦怠的一切，希望你能从中了解更多，从而尽可能保护自己，当然也包括你所服务的人。我是Claire Plumley博士，我是一名临床心理学家。我与那些
have gone through traumatic events, feeling anxious and feeling burned out. I've also written a book recently and it is out now. It's on this topic. Burnout is called Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. There's a link in the show notes to the book sales page. So in this episode, we're going to talk about the difference between stress and burnout. Often those words might be used interchangeably. So it's helpful to get a distinction between the two. I know I'm preaching to the converted when I say that not all stress is bad and our body is designed for stress. We have this amazing bit of kit, our autonomic nervous system, that in an ideal world would shift between its gear settings quite fluidly. When we're in our sympathetic nervous system gear,
经历过创伤事件、感到焦虑和倦怠的人一起工作。我最近也写了一本书，现在已经出版了。它就是关于这个主题的。书名是《倦怠：在神经系统控制你之前如何管理它》（Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You）。节目说明中有购书链接。所以，在这一集中，我们将讨论压力和倦怠的区别。通常这两个词会被混用，所以区分两者很有帮助。我知道我是在向内行人传道，因为并非所有的压力都是坏事，我们的身体就是为应对压力而设计的。我们拥有一个神奇的装备——自主神经系统，在理想情况下，它会在不同的档位之间流畅切换。当我们处于交感神经系统档位时，
this is an energized, motivated place. We might move from being in that ventral vagal parasympathetic branch, often known as green mode or rest and digest, into this kind of sixth gear where everything might feel a little bit more urgent. We get this urge to fix and get stuff done. We get more racing thoughts. And of course, we get the other allostatic changes, so the changes in our body systems to prepare us for that fight or flight response. Types of changes I'm talking about, again, I know you already know this, and I'm sure it's your bread and butter with your own clients, but it's your increased heart rate, it's the tense muscles, it's the shift of digestion into just essential
这是一种充满活力、积极进取的状态。我们可能会从腹侧迷走神经副交感分支（通常被称为“绿色模式”或“休息与消化”）切换到这种“六档”模式，一切可能感觉更紧迫。我们会有修复和完成任务的冲动。我们的思维会变得更加活跃。当然，我们还会经历其他的异位平衡变化，即身体系统为应对“战斗或逃跑”反应而做的准备。我所说的这些变化，我知道你们已经很了解了，我相信这在你们与客户的工作中也是家常便饭，比如心率加快、肌肉紧张、消化系统转入仅维持基本功能的
mode. And of course, our body isn't designed to stay in that gear for too long. We should come back to our rest and digest mode so that our body functions can resume business as normal if those sympathetic changes carry on for too long then this allostatic load builds up but what's more is that our attempts to try and flee or fight the situation if they continue but the chronic stress just doesn't let up then i think what happens is our nervous system dips into the gear that we talk about most in trauma therapy and this is the dorsal vagal system. This is a part of the nervous system that is more about energy conservation and survival mode. So imagine this, imagine you are practicing your tennis shots, you're practicing your shots against a tennis ball machine that's throwing the balls at
模式。当然，我们的身体并不适合长时间保持在这个档位。我们应该回到“休息与消化”模式，以便身体功能恢复正常。如果这些交感神经的变化持续太久，异位负荷就会累积。更糟糕的是，如果我们试图逃跑或战斗的尝试持续不断，但慢性压力却无法缓解，那么我认为我们的神经系统会陷入我们在创伤治疗中最常谈论的档位，即背侧迷走神经系统。这是神经系统中更多关于能量守恒和生存模式的部分。想象一下，你正在练习网球发球，对着一台不断向你投球的机器练习。
you. You've got this, you're hitting the balls back. But hang on a minute, now someone's rolling out a second tennis ball machine. So now you're having to work at twice the speed, you're hitting double the amount of shots. This is the equivalent maybe of stress at work. And then maybe there are problems with your children's schooling or things going on at home that you're going to have to deal with as well. But what if a third machine is pulled out? Maybe this is strains with friendships, or maybe you've got elderly parents who need caring for. This is what a lot of people I work with,
你接住了，你把球打回去。但等一下，现在有人推来了第二台网球机。所以你现在必须以两倍的速度工作，击打两倍数量的球。这可能相当于工作中的压力。然后，也许你的孩子在学校遇到问题，或者家里有事情需要你处理。但如果推来了第三台机器呢？也许是人际关系的紧张，或者你需要照顾年迈的父母。这就是我工作中的许多人，
and I'm sure you resonate with this in your own personal life, go through these times when we have the equivalent of multiple tennis ball machines throwing balls at us. And our attempts to hit these balls back can become quite frenetic. But if there's no let up we're trying to return the balls but we're not getting them all there's nowhere to escape there's no quick exit out the back of the tennis court then we might do the only thing left that's available to us we might curl into a ball to avoid being hurt by these shots as best we can
我相信你在自己的个人生活中也会产生共鸣，经历这些时刻，我们就像面对多台网球机向我们投球一样。我们试图回击这些球的努力可能会变得非常狂乱。但如果压力没有缓解，我们试图回球却无法全部接住，没有地方可以逃脱，网球场后面没有快速出口，那么我们可能会采取唯一剩下的选择：蜷缩成一团，尽可能避免被这些球击中受伤。
this is really similar to the learned helplessness idea that you might remember from your training days. This is where we see the symptoms described in burnout. Feeling hollow and like you're on autopilot, these are all signs that you're not functioning fluidly through your gears and that you either got stuck in that dorsal shutdown or you're oscillating between the sympathetic and the dorsal shutdown without really spending much time in that calmer rest and digest part of your nervous system. So hopefully this gives you an idea and a framework for understanding the difference between stress in a positive type of stress, which is also known as eustress, and distress, which tips into burnout. You might have come across it if you haven't, it's worthwhile looking up the Yerkes-Dodson curve, also known as the stress curve. It's a bell curve. I include it in
这与你在培训期间可能记得的“习得性无助”概念非常相似。这就是我们所描述的倦怠症状。感到空虚，仿佛处于自动驾驶状态，这些都是你无法在神经系统档位间流畅运作的迹象，要么是你陷入了背侧迷走神经关闭状态，要么是在交感神经和背侧关闭状态之间摇摆，而没有在神经系统中更平静的“休息与消化”部分停留太久。希望这能为你提供一个理解压力（一种积极的压力，也称为“良性压力”）与导致倦怠的“苦恼”之间区别的框架。如果你还没接触过，值得去查阅一下耶基斯-多德森定律（Yerkes-Dodson curve），也称为压力曲线。它是一条钟形曲线。我也把它包含在
my book as well, and it's quite a well-known one. So if you don't already know it, it's worth taking a look. I found in my work that having this understanding of the nervous system has helped to understand why certain techniques aren't quite right for where someone is. So for example, the type of advice that is often given for people who are burnt out makes so much sense. We need to rest, absolutely we do. And the kind of things that will help us do this is things like journaling, mindfulness, exercises to problem solve and time block, challenging unhelpful thoughts. These are all really sensible. However, a lot of them also draw on our cognitive faculties. And these are more available to us when
我的书中，它非常有名。所以如果你还不知道，值得一看。我在工作中发现，对神经系统有这种理解，有助于理解为什么某些技巧并不完全适合某人当前的状态。例如，人们通常给倦怠者提供的建议非常有道理。我们需要休息，绝对需要。而能帮助我们做到这一点的事情包括写日记、正念、解决问题的练习、时间管理、挑战无益的想法。这些都非常合理。然而，它们中的许多也依赖于我们的认知能力。而这些能力只有在我们
we are in our green rest and digest mode. Of course, our thinking switches gear into that more urgent, more rigid, more black and white type of place when we are in our sympathetic nervous system. And we really struggle a lot when we're in dorsal shutdown to have any ability to have creative thought or ability to have solutions or ways to start moving out of this stuckness so my argument in my book and where i provide tools is to try and soothe the nervous system to get back to that place because yes absolutely in the long term we need those things but they might not be immediately available and you might already have tools that you use these are often somatic type of tools for calming so my hands are on my heart right now because breathing using your hands to soothe yourself and using movement so if you already have tools up your sleeve for those make
处于“绿色休息与消化”模式时才更容易获得。当然，当我们处于交感神经系统时，我们的思维会切换到那种更紧迫、更僵化、更非黑即白的模式。而当我们处于背侧关闭状态时，我们很难进行创造性思考，也很难找到解决方案或开始摆脱困境的方法。因此，我在书中提出的观点以及我提供的工具，都是为了尝试安抚神经系统，使其回到那个状态。因为是的，从长远来看，我们确实需要那些东西，但它们可能无法立即实现。你可能已经有了自己使用的工具，这些通常是用于平静身心的躯体类工具。比如我现在把手放在心口，通过呼吸、用手安抚自己以及运动。所以如果你手头已经有这些工具，请
sure you're using them as frequently as you can and in a future one of these episodes I talk about doing that at certain transition points in the day so I'm going to sign this episode off and I hope it's been really helpful. I'm going to meet you in the next one where I'm going to start talking about the three different subtypes of burnout. You're going to want to hear that because it was a real penny drop moment for me when I learned about this. Thank you so much, Claire. That was absolutely wonderful. If this has whet your whistle please do check out the details for the book in my show note please do come and connect with me on socials let me know what you thought to this episode and come and follow Claire too where she is Dr. Claire Plumley
确保尽可能频繁地使用它们。在未来的某一集中，我会谈到在一天中的特定过渡点这样做。我要结束这一集了，希望它真的很有帮助。下一集见，我将开始谈论倦怠的三种不同亚型。你一定会想听的，因为当我了解到这一点时，我真的有一种醍醐灌顶的感觉。非常感谢你，Claire。这真是太棒了。如果这引起了你的兴趣，请务必查看我节目说明中关于这本书的详细信息，请务必在社交媒体上与我联系，让我知道你对这一集的看法，也去关注Claire，她在各处都是Dr. Claire Plumley，
everywhere come and join the free Facebook group the aspiring psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent which is the exclusive home of Marianne's mindset and motivation sessions, which happen weekly. If you're finding you've got a little bit more time on your hands at the moment, as well as reading Dr. Clare's book, you might well find the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book useful. So do check those out. And if you've read them, please take a moment to drop me a review on Amazon and or Goodreads as it really does help the books to reach a wider audience. Please do also take a moment to follow, subscribe to the show, which you
快来加入免费的Facebook群组“准心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent），这是Marianne思维与动力课程的专属基地，每周都会进行。如果你目前手头比较宽裕，除了阅读Claire博士的书，你可能还会发现《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书很有用。所以一定要去看看。如果你读过它们，请花点时间在亚马逊或Goodreads上给我写个书评，这真的能帮助书籍触及更广泛的受众。也请花点时间关注、订阅这个节目，你
can do on Spotify, on Apple Podcasts, and of course, YouTube. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcast that you are a big fan of. And of course it is totally free. Thank you so much for your time. I will look forward to bringing you the next episode, which will be along for you on Saturday at 10am on YouTube and wherever you get your podcasts from 6am on Monday. Stay kind to you and thank you so much for being part of my world. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent.
可以在Spotify、Apple Podcasts以及YouTube上进行订阅。这对你喜欢的任何播客来说都是最友好的支持方式。当然，这完全是免费的。非常感谢你的时间。我期待着为你带来下一集，它将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并于周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方发布。善待自己，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。这里是《准心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。
My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you
我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就停不下来。
start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。